[Music]
all right welcome back guys episode 7
we're making a little demo rpg game in c
plus plus and today we're gonna look at
some buffs and equipment
for our characters
and that's uh that's gonna be pretty
much the episode basically just prepping
up to start doing combat and start uh
tying together more
stats and stuff so uh thank you for
joining i appreciate you guys
and i hope you're looking forward to
some some coding all right so first
thing first let's get a little buff
system going on so let's go ahead and
just make a new class for these a new
struct
and we're just going to call it
uh buff
dot h
uh we might also make debuff 2 but for
now let's just make a quick struct of a
buff
and everyone probably knows what a buff
is it's basically something that's like
a temporary stat boost and that's all
this is going to be we're going to keep
it real simple so we're going to have
a uh
an unsigned end for uh we'll make it a
unit 16
for duration
just how long it's going to last because
above implies that it's temporary
direction duration and
we're going to need what it affects so
it's going to either be
strength agility or intellect pretty
much or it could be
armor or something like that so we
basically are going to go off this stat
block here
and it's going to buff this sort of
stuff we could also
buff shields or or
buff your health or things like that but
that's that's just going to be healing
really so we're just going to keep it
really simple so for now we're going to
go
like that
and we'll go to stat type and there
might be a case for making this here
because we're probably going to reuse
these a lot
that might be a case for making these
something
more simple
what am i including here i just type
stamp type like that was going to
do anything uh i was just thinking stat
lock really all we want is the stat type
but
i guess we'll include the whole thing
now we could do this
using some special c plus plus features
like we could basically make this sort
of an extension or a uh
what's the word for basically like a
an add-on to this which somewhat makes
sense but
it also uh we will probably do that
later because this is really all we need
we need a duration strength and or we
need a duration and what it buffs
so this way when we instantiate one say
what it does
and for how long and then as we go
through the rounds we can tick down the
duration and once they lose that
duration
uh
it'll stop doing its thing
so let's also give it a name and we
could also say
maybe it's a debuff
okay because there's a buff
and there's a debuff so let's just make
a bully in here and say
uh
is diva
because if it's a debuff we'll subtract
whatever the stat is
rather than add to it
and
we're just going to do this basically as
quickly as possible
and we're going to want a constructor
or
we could skip the whole constructor and
just say
you need to instantiate this set it up
how you want
and then
and then apply it so we still need a
system to apply it of course but we'll
do that here in a second so actually
let's make a constructor um and let's
just take
all this stuff in
we've been kind of doing that before you
know you probably noticed by now that
there's a lot of different ways of doing
this sort of stuff
you never know you know you never know
if you're doing it the best way until
you get further along in your program
and decide for you and the real the real
big point is here you've got to decide
for yourself on your own software when
you're doing stuff creatively uh what
one person does it might not be what the
other person does but both work fine so
you just have to pick one and move on
uh in my opinion it's really important
to not get stuck on the fine
mind you details of this way or that way
sometimes it makes a lot of sense if
you're having performance issues and you
need to analyze which way uses
less memory or is faster that could be
important
but if that's not a concern
you just need to move on and keep going
so hopefully that helps
some of you out there that get stuck
trying to figure out what to do next
uh the short answer is just do it that's
the answer
all right just do what works
we got a duration
and now let's put in the stat types and
you know what we're going to do this the
quick way
and just copy a bunch of this stuff
right on over maybe
these is here
all right so in our stack block here
we don't really have any way to apply
buffs but we will change that here
shortly
i'm just going to copy all those
i might just break to a new line here
because it's going off screen
so this will be strength and to make it
a little more clear here
and agility here
uh it doesn't like the word it of course
so
intel we'll call intel because it's a
keyword uh as you probably already know
but basically all we're going to do is
if we're constructing a new debug
because we're just above or debuff is
we're going to set all this stuff
and uh we also need to say
uh
for this one a boolean is
uh
trying to find a way i guess we could
just spell it
lowercase
and we have some default values here
which uh i guess we'll leave
it's either you know we have the choice
here we've been doing constructions a
couple different ways if we have
everything with a default value
in this constructor it's kind of the
same as putting an equals in front of
all of these and setting their default
values that way
but you know do whichever way you like i
i kind of mix it up
sometimes
uh duration i don't know we'll default
to round buff
but uh
yeah that should be fine now we just
need to actually set all these we got
name
going to be whatever the name is there
duration dirt you can probably see where
this is going
so
strength
hstr
uh intelligence
and it's uh
tell
try not to go over
let's see that's column 68 so we could
go a little wider but this is
somewhat optional here
so it depends on your formatting rules
for wherever you're working or whatever
uh i just typically
try to stick around 80 characters or
less but it depends sometimes i'll let
it go as long as it needs to be
but uh something like this just kind of
ensures that most people
will be able to see it on their editor
uh whatever editor they're using all
right so we've got the buff ready now we
just need a way to apply it because this
by itself isn't going to do a whole lot
other than just uh it's something it's a
buff it's a buff right so let's go over
to our stat block
and let's maybe
put like a apply buff
well let me think how do we want to do
this how do we want to apply this buff
okay we've got a couple options we could
add a method in here like we could do
something like this like include
a buff
so if we have that
then we could put a method in here
that is apply buff
and
we could keep track of the buffs on your
stat block
uh i don't know this method might be
fine the only problem here is
well i guess this isn't a big problem
because i'm thinking about this a little
bit here
yeah if we're applying buffs on the stat
block our player characters
uh have a stat block
so they'll all already have this method
that you can call
just from
from pc class so
uh if we do it this way we'll eventually
have something in our player character
and based on this pc class we'll be able
to do something like
let me just put it i'll just put it away
at the bottom here
avoid
uh fly
buff
and it will take a buff
whatever the type is buff here
and we'll basically just make it
call the method i guess this would be
forwarded because it's like a pc class
thing
uh and it'll go like something like this
supply buff
and move these passports
here
and uh that that should be fine so it
would look something i'm just
hypothesizing here really i haven't
really done this standard
vector buffs
and maybe we want a second one for for
debuffs here
because uh you'll see here i'll apply
some we'll apply some logic
okay uh so uh maybe we don't need both
of these because we have
uh the flag in here already if it's
whether it's a debuff or not so we could
just uh probably get rid of that
and uh that will be good enough
now we just need to wait to apply these
and to
to remove them basically
now we need to be applying these buffs
so this is where things get a little
tricky i guess uh well probably not that
tricky you got a buff
we're just going to
apply it to the stat block which is
going to be a pc thing
and
that should take care of it so we need
an apply buff method
basically here on the pc class and that
should be it so we'll just do it on the
the player character delegate here
we'll just make a a little function here
and we could even make it virtual do we
need to though
i don't think so
uh let's see access to the stat block
already maybe we just put that right on
the stat block
itself
i guess we just got to decide where we
want to put the function to do this
because i guess you know if we leave
this protected
then only the delegate could do it
and maybe that's what we want so let's
actually
put it in the protected area
and we'll just leave it alone
hmm but this does change
maybe some other things so we'll we'll
address those as they come up and we
might need to do a little tweaking of
this as we go we
you know we can pretty fairly assume uh
since we're inherited from stat block
we get all that stuff it's a protected
method
so thus only this delegate here can
to that can access it
and uh that's where we want to put the
supply buff basically
uh up there
to be called a little redundant at this
at this point but uh i think we'll
actually end up using it later so let's
just put this in here
uh we'll put it right here
apply
buff and all this is going to do avoid
here
uh is we're just going to take those
buffs
dot pushback and we want a block now we
have to decide are what's unique if we
have one with the same name already do
we not want to apply it we want to maybe
just refresh it if they apply above with
the same name
so that's probably what we want to do
not being the case uh this should be
buffs i believe yeah
that being the case because this will
just keep adding them to it uh so what
we actually want to do is we want to do
something like this or
let's maybe do an auto uh buffs and buff
buffs
just go through them all and just say
like if b is equal to
our b dot name
is equal to
buff dot name you know we're gonna do a
few special things here don't worry
we're actually we're gonna take this by
reference we might want to modify let's
do a little trick here to make sure this
works so this is the one we're bringing
in
this is the this is the one where
uh checking against
now make sure this is equals equals
otherwise it's going to set it to that
okay so since this is by reference
we are
actually working with the real one
from this vector not a copy so thus we
can modify it so we can say if the name
is the same
then we'll go
whichever one we're on
uh
dot duration
equals b dot duration we just refresh
the duration if they rebuff us and then
we'll return which means we get out of
this function and we don't end up
pushing back anything so thus if they
try to apply a buff that has the same
name as a buff they already have all it
does is refresh the duration to the
starting duration so you can uh rebuff
people rather just with that simple
method
and that
is going to be good for that and then if
it doesn't hit this return that means it
did not find one with the same name
and it's going to end up just pushing
that new one to our list of buffs
and that should properly
apply or reapply buffs with that's all
you need to do
and of course we're calling that down
here
in the player character you call apply
buff
it does it from a pc class
and applies it uh maybe
we'll just change these names a little
bit
i don't know we'll stick with our camel
case actually
it's fine i know it's uh it looks weird
but
you know doing this stuff this
abstracting like this it just gives us
options to do more logic here if we need
to kind of like we do with this mp and
we're going to keep doing that so
there's going to be a little logic here
and there that we end up doing quite
frequently
as we go
to keep this all sorted out for the
front end that is running so that's
ultimately the point of this player
character
is to just be able to add to it and do
all the required logic
as we need to because this after a while
this little player character is going to
get pretty large
okay here's where things start to get a
little wonky for us because
we have a duration of these buffs
right so we need them to eventually wear
off we don't need them we don't want
them to last forever
so when we call things like get strength
and get strength
uh should it be
getting this the base strength
or should it be getting the buff
strength so
we might actually need to do some
special stuff here and that's where
we're going to add in a few
new things because currently we have all
these
stats
which is somewhat fine but we could also
keep track of uh how much like the total
buffs
and we could uh work with that as well
so uh we'll just add that in um there's
maybe a better way to do this than i'm
thinking but let's just add it in as a
uh like a total buff
total
actually we'll call this something
different like uh well i do want total
on here i think total is good total
strength but at the end of these from
buffs
i'll just put from buffs on each of
these total strength from buffs
to intellect for buffs there we go now
we got this whole new set of stats
and these are all going to default to
zero so let's just do that real quick
let's zeroes on these so now what we
want to do anytime we apply a buff we
probably want to
re-total these
so anytime either a buff falls off or
buff gets added
we want to reapply
all of these
and we need to think about these methods
to get strength we all we want base like
these are the base strength
so maybe we'll actually just put that on
here but the rename
key and just rename this base
uh and rename
this one
base so we're just going to keep putting
this base word on on all these
and just expand this as needed
to
uh work with our bop system
so this whole buff system you might be
wondering okay
this is really adding a lot of
complexity do we really need to do this
there's a lot of abilities and stuff
we're going to do in the future that
requires us to be able to buff and
debuff
both for
players and monsters and this stat block
is going to be used for players and
monsters so yeah i do think it is quite
required for our particular design is
there a better way of doing it maybe
probably there usually is but at this
point that's not what we're worried
about
this is all base right these are all get
base
strength intellect etc
uh so let's just rename these throughout
our code
and then if you don't know what the
hotkey for this is it's just control r
bar
so let me just hover over the variable
or function hit ctrl r and alt control r
again
and it allows you to put the new name
here you hit enter
it prompts you and says hey it'll be uh
what are we doing here
and we're just going to apply
like so oh this one i want to do it too
this way we don't have to go throughout
all our code and manually
rename everything
so one of the super nice features about
using an ide
yeah there's a few annoyances here and
there like the tapping issue with macros
but overall the benefits outweigh the
negatives all right so we need to total
these up any time we apply a new buff
we've got buffs here
our apply is actually in the delegate
but we probably want to forward that
once again
to our
stat
buff thing to handle so if we push back
above
this will just add it to the vector it's
not going to do anything else special
so we need either
something like uh
buffs dot recalculate default right
after that
or we could just make a function that
says
uh box dot add two
and uh we'll just do something like that
uh so let's be like it add new buff here
and just
pass it that b
and that's going to do the pushback
and recalculate any time we do that
because we don't need to recalculate if
it just refreshes the duration that's
that's fine so let's go over to our
stat block here
and just make a protected function
called
add
new book
and this function is just simply going
to do the pushback and do a recalculate
so this should automatically fix
everything
anytime we do it and eventually we'll
have a remove buff that will also
recalculate so maybe we want a
recalculate function
uh in here as well
that can only be called from within
snapbox and no one else can mess with it
anytime you add or remove
we'll just use that function so let's
just uh work that out real quick
void
privately we're going to have a void
recalculate buffs i'll make this one
with the all lowercase underscore the
way i typically do private functions
debating on whether it should be
capitalized or not but we want to buff
here uh we're bringing it as a copy for
now i don't think we're gonna
we maybe we could do it as a reference
but
we'll work that out later if we need to
a lot of times you do want to be copying
things
a lot of times you don't it just really
depends on the situation and we haven't
sorted out that situation just yet but
we just need to make sure we're calling
this correctly over and play character
delegate here we go that
buff
seems happy with that all right go back
over here
and let's do the thing so if we have a
new buff what we're going to do is push
back you know now that i'm thinking
about this we could even do
this whole refresh logic
in the stat block as well which i kind
of like the idea
i just the more we can hide it away
and it just works properly the better
sometimes
uh and this will just be
buffs dot push back
b and then recalculate
calculate buffs
all that
and that is supposed to update all of
these
so we got git base but we probably want
get
total with that returns both
uh jumping around a little here but
you'll see it in a second so let's add
some new functionality here
that's just to get total
and this one will return
base plus
from buffs
so it's going to give you everything
and i guess if they want the difference
they could do to get total minus base
and they could figure out
how much they're getting from any
particular one of these we just don't
want to overdo the functionality if
there's ways the end user could
uh
arrange these function calls to get what
they want
if they need to so
just a little think it out loud there
uh my personal preference we're kind of
designing a lot of these classes as you
might realize by now basically like a
library
and we're using this main
as a thing to to use our libraries
that's basically how this is currently
playing out that's why these are all dot
h files
right now okay all right so there we go
we got a way to get the base we got a
way to get the total now we just need to
make sure we uh recalculate buffs very
carefully uh we're also going to
remove buff or
tick duration
maybe a tick duration would be better uh
we'll we'll come up with that a little
later though
so for now let's make sure we add them
correctly because
you know a tick duration would basically
remove them if the duration ran out and
then recalculate
and uh should be able to go from there
all right so let's recalculate basically
what we're going to do is just add to
everything that gets a new buff or add
them all together so we're going to just
uh take these stats right here and make
some temporary versions of them anytime
we call this
uh and we want to go through all the
buffs for auto do we want to do it by
reference now the answer here i think is
no because we're not going to modify any
of the buffs here we're just going to
get these new totals
uh i'm going to make these under case
control u
will undercase your
highlighted selection which is another
cool feature so i'm just going to
highlight all this and control u
that way it doesn't interfere with
these
and we don't want to shadow those ones
shadowings where you
have variables of the same name in
different scopes you try to avoid that
because it causes confusion it's called
b and buffs so we go through all the
current buffs
and we're just gonna say like
uh total strength well we'll just do all
these let me get this equals out of the
way so i can do a multi-select here
so we're basically just gonna do this
plus equals
uh b dot strength
plus equals
b dot intellect
now there's another thing you might have
caught this already that i need to fix
here because what if it's a debuff right
what do we do see if you can think of
that before i get to it
all right so that's going through all
the buffs but we can say if
uh
this current one
is a debuff
so if debuff is true here
we do something else
else we add
and basically that's going to be a minus
because these can't go negative
right these are all unsigned so if it's
a debuff we want to subtract but
if it goes if it tries to go below zero
we want to make sure it's
just zero we don't want to be able to
lower stats below zero otherwise
what's going to happen is that zero
since they're unsigned it's going to
wrap to a giant positive number so if
you debuff someone enough
and the code's a little buggy you're
going to actually give them millions of
stats so they'll be hitting for giant
numbers
uh because you debuffed them which will
make no sense and make people rage quit
uninstall your game and give it a bad
steam review so try to learn some code
logic before you release your game on
steam otherwise you're just going to be
ruining your own game which this happens
a lot i mean you see it you know every
game you've ever played has lots of bugs
hopefully they're not this significant
as the one i'm just talking about here
because it's pretty game breaking if you
debuff something and then it hits a
million times harder than ever before
now the simplest solution here is
probably to actually use integers
for the stat type and if it's negative
snap it to zero how we how are we going
to address that
yeah we'll probably actually just use
integers that's the easiest way i can
think of that to do that but this this
is actually really easy you went 16
and 16. bam problem solved and one
character thanks to this type def so
that is the beauty of these type def so
if you run into a scenario where
you need a different variable all over
the place rather than renaming it all
over the place you just do it in one
spot and it's amazing
and now we can easily figure out this
debuff logic and make sure it doesn't go
negative because the other case was if
we left him unsigned we would have had
to check if the debuff turned it into a
giant positive number and say hey if
this turned into a giant positive number
when it clearly couldn't have been then
just make it zero so uh you know we
could have handled it that way too but
just going with an integer i think is
fine
maybe we'll decide later we do want this
to be a unit
and we will do what i just said on the
other case there all right enough
yapping about that let's
get on to it it's basically going to be
the
the same as these
except it's going to be all minuses now
we just want a little logic here
as we go along and we could do it just
at the very end here
i think we'll do it at the very end so
we call recalculate buffs right we do
all this stuff
but this is just a temporary variable we
just want to get we're just working with
the totals so we need to apply this at
the end to the real totals
uh whatever it is so let's just take
these
total variables select just from here to
here and we'll just put it down here
and we'll just say they're equal to
whatever this total is after going
through this for loop and adding and
subtracting them all up
there we go
little copy pasta action and then we
want to make sure none of these are
negative so
uh that's you know that's just going to
be the logic of our game just they're
not going to be allowed to be negative
so we'll just take these totals
once again and do a final check here
and uh say if
it's less than zero then it equals zero
and we'll just do that for all of them
equals zero
uh yep so we're just going to take this
if
go down here
apply that a bunch it's less than zero
right there
we'll fix
the rest of this here in a second
just kind of doing this the fastest way
i can and we're going to let the
formatting
sort out the rest so
equals zero
zero put a little auto format button and
we're done any spaces here
we have now we now have a way to add
buffs
their duration doesn't tick yet but once
we get some combat going
we'll do that once we have some more
special abilities we'll be able to apply
them and stuff like that but for now
let's just
try adding some buffs to the warrior and
see how that goes we also actually hold
on we need to
forward this okay so when we call get
strength it's getting the base strength
so we need to think about how we want to
do that with our character
yeah i kind of think any time we're
getting the strength we want the total
not the base
but we might want
both
available so once again we could forward
some more functionality
or we could just say
uh we could just change these so
i don't know i i feel like when you get
the strength of something in general you
want the buffed strength
so we'll be getting the total here i
think or maybe we just add both let's
just actually add book uh let's just
forward these actually for now i i don't
particularly like this because it's just
a direct forward but it's okay uh and
let's make another one we just want to
be clear whether it's base or not all
right what's the clearest way to say
this get
i guess just total there's totals fine
and these will change into total as well
so yeah it's still just forwarding
functions uh that's fine though it's uh
yeah it's kind of ugly
but
these will change as we go
but basically when we get the total
yes we want the base the buffed plus
anything else applying it including
magical items uh potions things like
that i guess potions would probably just
apply a buff if they're gonna do
something but some things will give you
like a permanent buff and we don't
necessarily want that on the buff list
but maybe we do i don't know we'll have
to decide what the time comes but for
now let's go ahead and test all this
work we've done
so we've got our warrior
and we can
get his total strength
and we might be able to you know in our
interface once we get to graphically
putting stuff in there we'll be able to
make a character sheet and
and do special stuff like
uh
you know make numbers
red if they've been lowered below their
base and make them green if they've been
raised above their base at all so we'll
be able to do special stuff
uh with all this later using some some
logic that we've made we're looking good
you know let's add
a buff at some point let's say when he
gains this xp now we just need a place
to put this
so we'll just put it right here
specifically when they get to level two
let's go ahead and just add a buff so
we'll go p1 dot apply buff and we just
need to actually construct a buff here
or maybe we'll do harmful
i'm just
coming up with a
name here but we gotta actually make
this of course
call it arm buff and give it some
default values
now let's see it has a few constructors
ready to go there's the one we made that
allows you to put in whatever you want
and we'll just put in here
uh a bunch of stuff it's gonna
it's gonna be zero
wait no it needs a name uh we'll just
call it like uh stone shield sure
that's gonna be its name
duration
uh we're not ticking this yet but maybe
it's a 10 round thing so we'll put 10 in
there
and then for strength
if this is going to be
however much we want it's going to be 0
intelligence zero agility
zero
armor okay let's give them smarter let's
give them five armor
and then
element resistance
zero is it a debuff
uh it's defaults to false so we don't
actually need to put that in there
because the default value
uh is false
so actually we don't need to put this
zero in there either for the element red
we basically need to go as far as we're
changing things yeah all the ones before
yeah we gotta put something that's just
how the default value to work but once
you get to a point where the rest of the
stuff is default
uh since we designed it this way we can
just leave it off there and that will
apply them properly and then we again
we're going to go ahead and apply that
buff so once he gets to level two we
basically should see
that
our character has five more armor than
four
we don't have a way to list the buff
names yet but we could add that in there
we could do a little uh for loop and say
uh display buffs and buffs names
durations and you know that's that's
something more for a graphical interface
uh you know something you put on a list
of all your buffs and debuffs little
icons or something
uh but let's just go ahead and hit play
here make sure all this works
and we got a few errors so let's
observe these errors and fix them i love
this part i know sometimes to some
people errors are incredibly
intimidating
but really these are a great opportunity
to learn
something so these are
you should really take pride in being
able to figure out errors
all right we're getting unknown
specifier on strength uh what else we're
getting
uh unknown identifier this it doesn't
like the stat type variable uh we're
pulling that in from stat block right
stat type
yeah
missing type specifier stat type
okay so i think the problem we're
running into here is we need to include
the c standard int
which we have here
uh
so
that should work
i don't know i guess we'll just apply it
again it's kind of a little strange
there
but i think it just wants that let's go
ahead and build it again
and see what it does no same thing so
that's not the problem let's get rid of
that it's something else okay so i think
this is a cascade of issues like it
looks like one thing at first but if we
keep going down we eventually see that
it doesn't know what vector is so we
need to make sure we include vector here
because there's nowhere in the stat
block
or in the buff that we include here that
we say include vector
so
it's actually getting tied up there
and based on that it's not able to
compile this file and then the other
file is saying hey i don't know what
this is
that's because
another header couldn't be included
because it didn't work either
and uh
yeah so that'll cause some issues
so that's one of the problems there so
we got rid of that one let's see what
else the problem what other problem it
is no overloaded function takes six
arguments um
okay so
here's another problem here we
are taking this
buff
and passing it
a character array but what it actually
wants is a string so
a couple different things we could do
here
we could say
uh
let's take a character array instead all
right let's go
uh just hairstar
name
and that
is going to work a little better
this here
because this is a const care
you know 12 characters
and let's just make sure that works
nope still complaining a little bit okay
i got it figured out something a little
weird was happening it was actually all
about
uh
probably the order of something and the
way we're including something
but ultimately
it
seemed to have an issue with the whole
type def uh that we had right here
that was the stat type
so we had right here
uh what was it standard and 16 t you
know which is all valid
but for some reason
it wasn't take it wouldn't accept this
over in the buff and this might be
because we have buff included here maybe
we needed it below i don't know it was
something about the include order so
i should say as a fair warning like when
you're doing your project like this with
all
headers and only a main to build
everything
everything builds as a single object and
that's this main dot cpp turns into a
main.o and that turns into your
executable so you get like one object to
build off of
uh this is kind of one of the
disadvantages to doing this way so the
order that you include your header files
is critically important because if you
include them in an order where you
include one
uh first and has stuff required from a
one you include later
uh you're gonna get problems
with that and uh that i think that's i
believe that's what we were running into
was just the order
of headers being included somewhere was
not seeing what it needed to see so we
could like toy around with the order of
the headers
and how they were included but i decided
to just make a types header
that has what we need so we'll be
filling this out as we go so we got c
standard and we got
stat type here and anytime we need stat
type
like in buff we'll just include types
and stat block will include types and
this way anytime we need it we can just
include it at the top
and that will get c standard n and it'll
get our types
and uh that's gonna yeah i know we kind
of did away with that at one point but
since we're doing this header method
ultimately we probably want to do this
for the sake of reducing errors in the
future so that was the big thing of
course we did need vector as uh
as we said in that one part the the
bigger problem actually seemed to be
something about the way we were or the
order we were doing this include so yeah
this is going to be easier to have a
type file i think and we can go through
real quick and say hey we'll take this
one here
and we'll go and just put that in here
as well
this way you know as we continue to
build stuff
we can just uh you know if we're using
any of our special types
we can just go include types
and we can just do this anywhere
that we need it right at the top
this of course has pragma once so it's
not going to get double included or
anything let's just flip through the
rest of these make sure we got all our
types sorted out okay we got a few more
types here
uh we're going to get rid of the c
standard end
we're going to bring it probably go
ahead and put types here
and we're going to take these and also
just put them in our types
and there we go that uh sorts out a lot
of that let's just go through and make
sure
there's no more types to find anywhere
nope i mean we do have these enums
maybe those will end up belonging in the
types
but we're not going to worry about that
just yet
so let's go ahead and just build this
make sure it builds it looks like it is
and what we should see now when we run
it
is once we get to level two on this
warrior we'll get an armor buff that
gives us five armor for 10 rounds rounds
aren't calculated yet but we should
basically see
at level two we get five bonus armor
from this debuff or from from this buff
rather
because we're calling get total armor
here which is going to include the base
plus the buffed
and uh yeah that should
let's go ahead and hit play make sure
all that works
there's the level one warrior zero armor
as you can see goes to level two
gets his power attack ability and gets
five armor
uh from that buff but now now once we go
to battle
we can do some kind of uh tick the buff
durations
and see if they fall off or not if they
do recalculate
then it basically should keep these
accurate
throughout the whole
uh system
and i think that's going to do it for
this episode you can probably
extrapolate how to uh
add more buffs here you basically just
apply a buff
as needed um
but uh currently yeah they're not going
to fall off so right now anytime you
apply a buff it's just permanent
but we will change that probably in the
next episode we'll probably get to uh
to do that so
yeah that should be that should be good
now um
of course uh this supports debuffs as
well uh all we'd have to do to do that
is go
uh what we need element res there and
debuff true
so this is a debuff it's going to
subtract 5 armor now or warrior already
has zero armor so based on our current
armor if you subtract five
uh
what should it do and uh well the answer
is
right in our apply buff logic here in
our stat block or recalculate and that
is well if it goes below
zero it should set to zero so let's just
try this as a debuff and just make sure
at level two
it is actually zero yep that looks good
so that seems to be all working
correctly
and uh not not seeing any problems with
that
so
from here we can just
uh call it a day all right see you guys
next time thanks for watching greatly
appreciate all of you
and uh peace
keep coding
[Music]
you